my buddy asked me to throw him a
bachelor party right and so um
so there's a bunch of this um that that
if you haven't seen it live you haven't
seen most of uh
the worst things that happened to my
friend
so he asked me to throw the bachelor
party
i said no and i said no because i know
me
and i know that if you ask me to do
something seriously for you
i'm not god like as soon as he asked me
i was like well i'm gonna [ __ ] i'm gonna
[ __ ] him up
i'm gonna might do something terrible to
him you know and he's i said you don't
want me to do this dude
you just don't want me to i'm gonna [ __ ]
up your day he goes nah man you've been
to vegas more than any of us
just plan the party and get the girl i
said all right
so i i did get him a girl from the end
of the party
and one thing by the way that nobody
i haven't talked about is i did get him
a girl there was a girl
in the hotel room waiting for him for
the end
but when i told him i go you got to go
in that other room
he didn't trust me to go because i had
just
unleashed the fury on him you know what
i mean so
so um the black dance went to
somebody else uh
ah
i was like oh i can't let it go to waste
i mean [ __ ] you know
so i said all right i'll get you the
girl man but i wanted something that
entertained me at the top of the store
at the top of the
party and what entertains me is weird
[ __ ] guys i like weird i like weird [ __ ]
weird [ __ ] makes me laugh
where did i think i could find something
weird for him i went on craigslist in
vegas
and i was just looking through it and oh
there's so many good weird
things on craigslist i'm scrolling
through and i'm scrolling through
and i pass all the sex stuff and i land
on the weird
and the weird was three words and her
phone number and the advertisement just
said
i'll wrestle you and i was like [ __ ]
yeah you will
that at least deserves a phone call you
know so i call her on the phone now on
the phone
she told me she was six foot 250. on the
phone
and um she told me that her
skill set is she comes to your house she
gets naked
and she beats the [ __ ] out of you for a
little while
[Laughter]
yeah i was like well what time can you
get here
[Applause]
and so she asked me by the way she did
ask me she goes you want me to send you
a picture i go
oh you painted a pretty good picture i
know who's coming over
you don't need to validate yourself all
you said is six with 250 and after that
it was like
right now so she shows up at the hotel
and i'm the only one there
now here's the first thing my friend
never wanted me to tell you
ready for this first thing you ever
wanted to tell you is when i opened the
door six foot was real
250
not real she was
deep into the threes
deep deep deep
into the threes and i asked her i go hey
how come you didn't tell me you were
over
250 pounds and she said well i didn't
want to scare you away
and i told her i go i just so you know
for the future of your business
anybody who's calling about 250
isn't scared of 300.
you could you could charge me extra is
all i'm saying but i mean
you should be charging by the pound but
i'm not your manager so
and so she was holding a foot long sub
and 24 buffalo wings
she just waved them at me and she goes
you got a room where i could go fuel up
before the match
and i was like first of all [ __ ] yes i
do it's right from there actually
i said second of all you should know
that the person you're wrestling today
doesn't know there's gonna be a match
i don't know if that changes your
professional approach at all but i
thought you should know right
so she goes off into her room to eat i'm
assuming
and uh my buddy comes over and he's
sitting down on the stool and i got him
blindfolded
and here are a couple other things that
he never wanted me to tell you he's the
square square i've ever met in my life
he's marrying his high school sweetheart
he's never
seen another woman naked before
guys do you understand this is only the
second
naked body
he will ever have seen in his life oh
he's gotta
[ __ ] him up right i can't wait you know
what i mean
he sent me a text two weeks before the
party
that just said do all boobs feel the
same and i was like oh my god
i can't wait for this [ __ ] party
and he told me he was ready and i said
cool and i call her out now
none of my other friends knew what i had
planned so when she walked out of that
room naked collectively
they were like
[Music]
[Applause]
and as you get closer i can see that she
still had buffalo wings
i just gotta get her napkin but i was
like man your face is so funny
so my buddy is sitting there and here's
the thing he's not a big dude he's five
eight 140 if he's wearing a lot of
[ __ ] clothes like he's a tiny dude
man
and he was but he was so excited there
was a naked woman standing in front of
him
his hands were shaking and he was like
oh
i'm so excited and i was like huh
me too hey guys i just sit back and i
was looking at him for a second
both of them my buddy 5 8 140
blindfolded trembling like a leaf on a
stool
standing in front of him naked six foot
deep into the threes
and i'm just looking at the two of them
and i'm thinking to myself
this was a good purchase
buyer's remorse on this purchase like i
am already a hundred percent
i have three kids this is already the
best night of my [ __ ] life like
but i've known this dude forever man so
i lean into him i go man this one make
sure we're cool
uh i know you're marrying your high
school sweetheart and your life partner
but you've got a naked woman standing in
front of you
do you want me to send her home and he
gets serious
he goes you better not
and i said well just remember you said
that and
let's get started you know and i take
off his blindfold
and the only word he could get out of
his mouth
before she ripped him out of his chair
was why like that right
[Applause]
and she yanked him up in the air and his
little feet were dangling in the air
she started tossing around like a room
like a rag doll and i was like
she would jump on top of him and he had
to push her fat out of his face to talk
to us
he was like tell him to stop how long is
she gonna be here
i can't breathe why does she smell like
buffalo wing sauce all right
at one point in time she had her knees
on his elbows pinning him down to the
ground
and she was just beating him in the face
with her titties just
[Music]
and these aren't five foot two 110 pound
big big titties this is six
foot deep into the threes
just
that's how big her titties were they
made that noise through the air just
it was like being hit with a tint
missile just
you know what it sounded like it sounded
like if you closed your eyes it sounded
like a titty pterodactyl just
you know you know like in the rocky
movies
when he hit by a punch and his whole
face would go oh
one titty was like right
so look if you've seen the video online
you it cuts right now to me talking
about him
her standing here and him standing here
matt so what he never let me tell you is
why he was so mad
so i will tell you so she stands up to
take a rest
he's on his knees here's a couple things
you need to know that have been
happening all night
that he obviously never wanted me to
tell you
first of all she's been undressing him
so at this point of the night he's
wearing boxers
one sock oh it's been a rough night for
my man you know what i mean it's
not been a good time for him you know so
here's another thing by the way
you have to know how much i love this
woman we all went out and got [ __ ] up
after the party
she was amazing guys let me tell you how
much of a gangster
this woman was one of my buddies got so
drunk he couldn't walk out of the bar
she picked him up over the shoulder
fireman carried him out of the [ __ ]
bar
and let me tell you why she was so good
you know how you're kind of bouncy when
you're getting firemen carried right
he's bouncing balancing and at one point
he just looks up and she goes
he just looks up and goes i think she
just farted in my face
right
she didn't miss a beat she just goes
that's right [ __ ] like that just what
i was like i love this woman you know
but so the other thing i really liked
about her is that she was really
passionate about her job i like people
who like what they do
and she paid attention to detail how did
i know that so her one
sock leaving that on was important to
her that was attention to detail that
was
her way of telling him hey you don't get
to decide
[ __ ] tonight because he hated that one
sock
he hated it because he could never get
his footing he always slipped when he
tried to brace himself right
so he hated it so he kept taking it off
and throwing it across the room
but every time he did she would walk
over and pick it up
sit on his chest and put that
[ __ ] back on him
like a [ __ ]
every time she did there's a little tear
that came to my eye i'm like i love you
so much
guys he was head to toe sweat she had
been beating
the [ __ ] out of him for 20 or 25 minutes
and i know a lot of people think that's
hyperbole when i say it it is not she
was
noticeably bigger more than twice his
size
she was legitimately way stronger than
him
and here's how you can tell someone is
stronger than another human being
because there were parts of the night
and this still makes me laugh
when i think about it there were parts
of the night where she would
the visual is great where she would just
grab him by the shoulders
and this how you could tell she was
stronger than she was just grabbing by
the shoulders and just
[ __ ] shaking
and his whole body just
you know what he looked like he looked
like you don't you know those uh wind
socks out in front of a tire store that
he
it looked like he didn't have any bones
in his little body she was just [ __ ]
him up you know what i mean
i was like oh she's gonna rearrange his
organs like he's in trouble you know
he was breathing like this
because every time she got him on the
ground she would smother him with her
gigantic boobs and i guess he couldn't
breathe
because when she moved his boobs his
head would pop up like this
like he'd been under water for 20
minutes just
right so she's standing here
she just [ __ ] him up and he goes to
crawl off the floor
he didn't get up and walk this dude has
no energy for that
he's crawling off the floor and she's
standing on the other side of the room
and she gave him uh what i like to call
five feet of hope
because he really thought he was about
to get away you know what i mean
and she just took like two giant strides
[Music]
grabbed him by the ankle looked at all
of us
and just went
she was so much stronger than both of
his legs
popped up in the air right bam he landed
on the ground
and she starts to slowly drag him back
to the middle of the room guys he
doesn't want any card in the middle the
middle of the room is where the bad [ __ ]
happens you know what i mean
that is his sunken space my man does not
want any part of the middle
of the room you know what i mean and
he's grabbing at things but she just
keeps yanking him along and by the way
when she was dragging him slowly like a
caveman
she was eyeballing all of us
yo i was like i'm kind of hard right now
i'm scared and aroused at the same time
i don't know what's happening to me
she brings him back to the middle of the
room and
here's you'll know why he never wanted
to tell the story
she brings it back in the middle of the
room she picks him up by the ankle with
this hand
and with this hand checks the oil finger
in the [ __ ] right
a finger that we found out later still
had buffalo wing sauce on it
yeah that's why he was so mad it makes a
lot more sense now right
yo my man snapped he was just sitting
there and you know when you've seen your
buddy snap you they just go dead face he
was just like
and he just looks at her and he goes i'm
gonna [ __ ] you up
she wasn't even nervous she wasn't
scared she just been beating this little
dude up for almost a half an hour you
know what i mean
she just digitally raped him she's got
no problems
with this dude you know and he makes the
threat and she just goes
and he runs right at it and
screams at the top of his lungs i'm
gonna
take you down
right and he takes off and just starts
sprinting
she's just kind of standing there and he
ran into her with everything he had
and by the way great form title head up
shoulder in it made that loud slap
because they were both sure this you
know
it was amazing and he hit her hard and
he tried to take her down and i'm going
to tell you something right now
he did not
it happened exactly the way all of you
were picturing it
because when his little body hit hers
she just absorbed him for a second you
know
he even disappeared i was like hey where
the [ __ ] did he go
and then she just pooped shot him out of
her belly just
boom and he slid on the floor and my
friend ran up to him and was like
that just [ __ ] happened to you
and i turned to her let her go home guys
she starts dancing like this
and i'm like oh the night's not over
she told me later the night would have
been over but he challenged me
nobody challenges me and i was like oh
[ __ ]
so she she's standing there she goes you
want to see my finishing move you want
me to finish them and i was like
if i had known the finishing move was on
the menu i'd ordered that [ __ ]
at the beginning of the party are you
kidding
you've got a finishing move let's see
that right
so she's standing next to him she goes
finishing move and we go yeah she wants
that finishing movement
yeah she was finishing move and we go
yeah
and then she just sat on his head and we
went
[Applause]
guys this dude's head disappeared
all you could see were his tiny arms
slapping her back
it was the craziest thing i've ever seen
it was like a reverse birth it was
[ __ ] up right
[Applause]
now a couple other things
so i run into his dad and by the way
this is when you know you've pulled a
good practice good practical jokes or
any jokes to continue to pay dividends
for you
long after your jokes so i run into his
dad about a month and a half after the
party two weeks before the wedding
and um he goes to me and goes hey you're
not coming to the way
i was uninvited to the wedding by the
way uh
totally worth it so i would trade a
friend today for a story like that [ __ ]
him
um i gotta show you how he undervited me
this is my favorite part of the story
this is my favorite part of the story
this is how he invited me we're still at
the party
she had just gotten off of him oh man
and he stands you're not coming to the
wedding
[Applause]
okay i'm going to tell you something
else and this this this
never gets told all right so he
developed a nickname that night
i'm part of the being a storyteller is
answering your own [ __ ] questions so
if you shut up for a second i will
get to it i know you're annoying me from
up here i can only imagine
what's happening to the people you're
sitting next to but if it was earlier in
the show i'd address it but i'm like i'm
gonna be out of here in 10 minutes so
she'll just annoy those people too
okay so here is
this is the nickname okay
so he gets up and um
he's walking out of the living room to
go
into the bathroom to hang himself on the
side
and my friend i have a friend of mine
who was there
and he's one of the darkest
he has one of the darkest sense of
humors which is one of the reasons that
i think
you know he's one of my dear friends and
um but he was sitting there
and i knew he had something up the
sleeve because he he got a little smile
on his face
when my buddy was walking up to him so
my buddy's walking up to him
and this is the nickname he got he goes
damn man you look like a glazed donut
[Applause]
[Applause]
so i wasn't invited to the wedding but i
made all the groomsmen glazed doughnut
t-shirts right
and when he was walking down the aisle
they all just gave him up
[Applause]
and then his mom the week after the
wedding called me and was like do you
have any
extra of those cute gloves donut
t-shirts
she goes i love glazed doughnuts i'm
like yes so does your son
oh i got her one for every day of the
week
my buddy called me he was like my mom
loves that [ __ ] t-shirt man
but anyways his dad goes uh
you're not coming to the wedding i go
now and he said why that
and i said oh
tim didn't tell you and he goes no
is there a story and i go do you have a
couple minutes sit up sit down
[Applause]
and then his dad used that story
as his best man speech the what
[Applause]
and i asked him i go hey why would you
do that to your son
and he goes tim shouldn't have been such
a [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
you